let's discuss the aid effort that is now
going to follow that This Disaster
joining me from Beirut home baleen
dulier who's an emergency program
manager for Syria at the Catholic Agency
for overseas development also known as
kayford uh active in that part of the
world and whole baleen it's a difficult
situation already in Syria isn't it what
are your teams on the ground able to
tell you about what is happening in
these areas that have been worst
affected today
yeah as you said it's already very dark
it was already a dire situation in in
Syria and the needs were already
um extremely high
um so now our partners are on the ground
um they're trying to assess the
situation
um have a sense of the the the scale of
of you know the the disaster
um they've been uh supporting the
ongoing human humanitarian efforts
um which was you know supporting rescue
efforts providing shelters to those who
have lost their homes
um we know that
um medicine Food Water Shelter are um
also um winterization materials are
highly needed because the situation the
weather is extremely cold at the moment
um
um so yeah so that our partners are are
trying to respond to I mean are
responding to this and um and we're
supporting this uh this response at the
moment
and and we're looking at pictures from
Turkey of course which is much easier
for the media to access that than Syria
um in terms of the kind of equipment
that's in Syria how challenging is it
going to be to get the equipment that
you need to the places that are worst
hit
but our partners are already
um you know responding on the ground but
it is it is going to be very challenging
because the you know the the conflict
has been lasting for 12 years now uh so
the infrastructure was already
um very weak
um so that's also why like so many
buildings have collapsed
um so partners are yeah in a very
difficult situation Now to respond and
uh even the rescue teams don't have
everything they need
um so it's it's extremely difficult but
um our partners are able to uh get you
know all the the the emergency
um materials needed they can provide you
know blankets winterization materials
and so on
um for for the people in need
and and how easy is it for you to get
International Help in because we've seen
that a lot of different countries are
coming forward and saying that they are
willing to help they would like to send
equipment uh but without getting
involved in the politics of Syria uh a
lot of countries don't have diplomatic
relations with Syria and how then will
that Aid get in are there channels that
you can get Aid in
yeah I mean organizations on the ground
are mobilized mobilizing um sorry
available resources to provide quick
emergency assistance
um we have launched an appeal to um to
collect donations once we have you know
um you know with donations we would be
able to get um to get some humanitarian
assistance inside Syria
um we've been responding to numbers of
emergencies in in the region so that
yeah that's that's feasible
um and in terms of the the
infrastructure it was already damaged
wasn't it but how worse is it now as a
result of what's happened overnight
but I yeah it's it's um it's a disaster
um you know that's a humanitarian
disaster
um it it has a you know devastating
impact on populations
um so infrastructures were already
damaged um as I said before so
um you know the people have been
millions of people have been relying on
humanity and aid for years
um since the conflict started 12 years
ago
um so this is just you know another
another layer
um in
of Need for people
um people have been you know we're
already extremely extremely vulnerable
inside Syria and um and this is only
going to
um increase their needs um as as the
situation is going to continue
deteriorating
and in terms of actual sorry but in
terms of actual Communications with with
the worst hit areas are you able to get
through to those who are in those areas
yes we yes we're coordinating with our
partners um in Syria in Turkey
um and uh I mean it's been difficult to
communicate because of because of the
Telecommunications issues and the
infrastructure that have been damaged
but um we yeah we are we are in touch
with them coordinating with them uh to
to support the the ongoing humanitarian
response
and in terms of of what a lot of the
people that you are helping actually
have there in Syria at the moment I mean
these are people without a great deal to
call their own
it just doesn't bear thinking about how
much more difficult it is if they lose
the temporary shelter the temporary
accommodation the bits and Bobs of their
lives that they've managed to carry with
them up to this point
yeah people have been living in extreme
poverty
um it's you know it's another as I said
it's just going to be another
it's going to deepen their vulnerability
even more
um people already had limited access to
water food lots of people millions of
people had been displaced inside Syria
um some of them have lost everything
they had before uh now not like now
through the earthquake
um it's an incredibly dire situation
um so yes it's it's just it's
devastating devastating situation
um and it's going to have a very long
long-term impact on people's people's
lives
um so people have lost their I mean some
people have lost their lives people have
lost their homes
um and and some will have lost their
livelihoods so that impact is going to
last for not just for days or months but
for years
Colby and Julia from k-fod very good to
talk to you today thank you very much